ban
une équipe de quatre athlètes de haut
niveau donc français et canadien du coup
par rapport à ça donc il ya un processus
de sélection propres à leur propre à
l'organisation dieu de l'ifsc donc la
fédération international d'escaladé par
rapport à ça là il ya fanny gibert qui
était en phase de se qualifier mais ça a
été arrêté les sélections ont été
arrêtés au vu du contexte actuel il ya
notre athlète sean mc coll qui est
qualifié mais du coup qui on attend
entre guillemets de la date et il est
confiné chez lui au canada dont qui
continue à s'entraîner à se préparer
pour les géo qui a priori sont sont des
cas les certitudes sont décalés d'année
prochaine
pour nous deux athlètes du coup il ya
une meilleure localisation la plus
totale sur un point de vue entraînements
parce que du coup il ya plus de
structures qui sont disponibles ils sont
confinés chez eux tout simplement donc
il ya une adaptation de leurs systèmes
d'entraînement de leur préparation il ya
un ami gilbert faut gérer la frustration
du du report encore de cet événement
pour ce dernier ticket olympique donc il
ya une pression qui a encore créé encore
accentuée vis-à-vis de sa tâche qu'on ne
sait pas comment ça va se dérouler ni où
surtout quand donc on a il faut ajuster
l'implication de son entraînement chez
elle avec très peu de matériel est gérée
gérait cet événement et c'est attendre
le château
les athlètes vont pouvoir se réentraîner
dans les pôles france beaucoup plus que
dans les salles privées
au vu du contexte actuel et de la
liberté du nombre de personnes qui sera
tolérée dans les structures privées et
du coup ils vont devoir se rabattre à
100% dans le dans les pôles france